[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mardi 3 juillet bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle édition du 7 8
journal sur tv 78 le résumé de
l'actualité locale et régionale
tout de suite les titres la région
souhaite poursuivre sur sa lancée après
une bonne année 2010 est record dans le
secteur l'île de france a présenté hier
son dispositif tourisme parmi les
mesures principales un pass spécial
ryder cup ou encore le retour des
volontaires du tourisme dans un instant
entretien avec la présidente de la
collectivité valérie pécresse à
chevreuse désormais les habitants
peuvent payer en euros est aussi dans
une autre devise la racine a été mise en
circulation depuis dix jours dans
plusieurs commerces de la commune et des
alentours
invité de ce journal christian portal
président de l'association l'aracine
pour le collège des particuliers enfin
le burger et le sandwich le plus
consommé par les français ils inspirent
les plus grands un agriculteur
d'auffargis a lancé une compétition du
meilleur burger qui a mis aux prises
vous le verrez est et chef étoilé du
territoire mais avant de développer ses
titres de nombreux chantiers cet été à
saint quentin en yvelines les routes et
voiries seront en réfection certains
travaux ont débuté d'autres démarreront
dans les prochains jours et forcément
des restrictions de circulation et
déviations
elles sont à prévoir pour les
automobilistes yvelinois le point
complet avec tout ignorer lanto
vacances est possible mal en patience
pour les automobilistes yvelinois
plusieurs travaux ont lieu cet été dans
le département le poncho l'air va être
doublée entre les communes de maurepas
et la verrière quant au pont cache un
attrape il va être réaménagée en vue de
couvrir la nationale 10 la voirie quant
à elle n'est pas en reste quelques
kilomètres d'enrobé seront posées dans
l'agglomération six communes sont
concernées elles encourent guyancourt
magny les hameaux
montigny le bretonneux trappe et voisins
le bretonneux
les travaux commencent dès le 9 juillet
outre les automobilistes les cyclistes
ne seront pas oubliés une nouvelle piste
cyclable s'ajoutera à celles existantes
à elancourt
même chose à magny les hameaux le long
de la départementale 195 tous ces
travaux devraient se terminer d'ici à la
rentrée de septembre
cela ressemble à un début d'été parfait
soleil et chaleur s'installe sur
l'ensemble de l'île de france depuis
plusieurs jours une bonne nouvelle
forcément aussi pour le secteur du
tourisme
après une année 2010 est record avec 48
millions de touristes accueillis est la
région poursuit ses efforts pour attirer
français et étrangers dans la capitale
et sa région est la présidente valérie
pécresse présentait hier ses différentes
mesures pour y parvenir elle lancement
d'un pass à partir de septembre lors de
la ryder cup pour combiner transport et
visites ou encore le retour des
volontaires du tourisme ces gilets
violets et qui vous guide près des
monuments et points clés franciliens
nicolas kirilow vite c'est patrick
jacques de dixmude était présent à paris
pour le lancement de cette opération
séduction
après une année 2016 terrible pour le
tourisme en ile-de-france avec les
attentats et les intempéries la région
ile de france s'est fortement mobilisée
pour faire revenir les touristes en
ile-de-france et en 2010 cette année
record comparé aux 10 dernières années a
passé les touristes sont revenus en
masse à paris et dans sa région 2018
semble marquer la même tendance sur les
premiers mois et selon les premiers
chiffres qui sont à notre disposition
parmi les dispositifs mis en place par
la région
les volontaires du tourisme ces jeunes
qui ont un k-way violet et qui guide les
touristes dans les endroits clés de la
capitale et de la région et notamment au
château de versailles
la troisième saison de ces volontaires
du tourisme est lancée ce lundi au
palais de la porte dorée à paris
c'est la troisième saison valérie
pécresse des volontaires du tourisme ça
prouve que c'est un dispositif qui
marche
concrètement pourquoi s'est appréciée
par les touristes ces volontaires du
tourisme vous savez que nous avions
perdu un million de touristes après les
tragiques attentats du bataclan et
ça avait causé la disparition de 30000
emplois en ile de france 2 qu'il fallait
évidemment donner un
un coup de booster au tourisme et on a
travaillé sur la qualité de l'accueil
vous savez ce qui est souvent reproché
aux français un mal parler les langues
ne pas être suffisamment accueillant
vis-à-vis des touristes et ses 600
volontaires du tourisme qui vont être
déployés dans tous les sites
touristiques
ce sont des jeunes sont des jeunes de
bts sont des jeunes de licence de
lettres qui n'ont pas forcément la
possibilité de trouver un stage et qui
grâce à sa vont pouvoir exercer le
métier de leur rêve un métier dans le
tourisme non on soutient le tourisme en
ile de france il y a les volontaires du
tourisme mais pas que lui aussi le pari
regine pas ce qui va être lancée
justement du côté de saint quentin en
yvelines pour la ryder cup
oui alors le pari jen passe c'est enfin
une carte unique à la fois de transport
mais aussi pour faire des croisières sur
la seine mais aussi pour avoir accès à
un certain nombre de musées nous voulons
avoir le maximum de partenaires sur se
passe de façon à éviter de devoir
transporter sa carte bleue du liquide
sur soi
ce qui évidemment est source de
pickpockets d'insécurité donc impasse
très simple très rapide pour les
transports pour les musées et qui a
vocation à terme à se retrouver sur
votre smartphone est ce que vous diriez
qu'après une année 2016 terrible une
année 2010 est encore ce que vous diriez
que ça y est c'est reparti véritablement
pour le tourisme en ile-de-france qu'il
n'ya plus vraiment de soucis à se faire
pour le tourisme pour le secteur
touristique elle de france on vient de
battre une année record
et c'était un terrible soulagement après
l'année 2010 est horribilis qu'on avait
connue mais je crois qu'on est encore en
sous-développement notre potentiel
touristique et c'est particulièrement
visible dans les yvelines où finalement
à côté de versailles il ya énormément de
destination touristique de thoiry aux
maisons des illustres à la maison bizet
à la maison gloom à la maison d'aragon à
la maison de jean monnet aux maisons aux
maisons le corbusier vous voyez je les
cite au fur et à mesure et je me rends
compte à quel point finalement on en
oublie quand on en suit donc le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est de déployer cette
offre touristique de la faire connaître
à travers une plateforme de marché
unique qui s'appelle visitent paris ri
john parce que la première chose qu'un
touristes coréens tape sur son
smartphone quand il arrive à roissy
c'est pas yvelines s'est pas seine et
marne
c'est paris et donc il faut les sortir
de paris paris sqi jones est une marque
mondiale qu'on va développer et cette
plateforme intégrée qui intègre tous les
sites des huit départements
ça va être notre outil on va la traduire
en dix langues et on pourra y réserver à
la fois sa chambre d'hôtel son passe
navigo et aussi ses billets pour les
musées venir la question sur les
mouvements sociaux qui pourraient
éventuellement durée du côté de la sncf
cet été est ce que ça aussi c'est
quelque chose à craindre et qui joue
énormément sur le tourisme en ile de
france
franchement comme dirait jaurès il faut
savoir arrêter une grève
ce mouvement de grève n'a plus de sens
la réforme allait voter et désormais je
crois qu'il faut laisser les français
travailler et les touristes venir
visiter l'île de france et ce sont donc
600 jeunes étudiants en tourisme qui
seront déployés dans l'ensemble de la
région pour accueillir et guider les
visiteurs cet été ils seront par exemple
à proximité du château de versailles est
depuis le lancement de ce dispositif il
y a deux ans près de 1600 personnes ont
arboré leur gilets violets
mais alors pourquoi des sites il de
passer cet été au service des touristes
écouter la réponse de l'un de ces
volontaires recueillis par nicolas
kirillovitch et patrick jacques de
dixmude
j'ai déjà été dans ces situations en
fait j'ai travaillé beaucoup voyagé
à travers le monde et tout je sais que
quand un tourisme contre un touriste
pardon il vient il est vraiment perdu
tout ça il sait pas où aller c'est pas
quoi faire machin du coup on a vraiment
besoin de quelqu'un pour se sentir
vraiment familier dans ce pays et tout
du coup pour moi j'aime bien aider les
gens de reims et pour moi c'est plus
c'est plus que 80 volontaires mais c'est
une passion pour moi c'est une passion
franchement et voilà c'est pour moi
c'est un plaisir à montigny le
bretonneux les étudiants de l'estaca ont
désormais un lieu dédié à l'innovation
et à la réalisation de projets ouverts
depuis plus d'un an le fab lab vient
d'être inauguré officiellement ce
laboratoire du futur permet d'imaginer
et de fabriquer les mobilité de demain
un vrai plus pour l'école d'ingénieurs
visite avec aurélie ronze et/ou qui
nirhy lanto avoir à sa disposition
toutes sortes d'outils pour la
conception et la réalisation d'objets
une opportunité possible pour les
étudiants de l'estaca grâce aux fab lab
ce concept né aux états unis est un
laboratoire de fabrication numérique
intégré au sein de l'école d'ingénieurs
basée à montigny le bretonneux le lieu
est en libre accès sous la supervision
d'un fable manager ils viennent pour des
pour des projets personnels ou pour des
projets associatifs ou pour des projets
liés à la formation sachant que nous on
a des rares chizé évidemment donc on dit
les la règle c'est que les projets
associatifs sont prioritaires et puis
après les projets formation et
personnels fraiseuse numériques
imprimantes 3d machine qui permet de
graver des circuits imprimés
le fab lab a été cofinancé par la région
ile-de-france et saint quentin en
yvelines depuis son ouverture il ya un
peu plus d'un an il a permis la
réalisation de plusieurs projets comme
un bateau adapté aux personnes
handicapées ou encore la fabrication
d'une fusée expérimentale
parmi les avantages apportés par ce
laboratoire un gain de temps pour lé
prototypage
si on passe par les moyens
conventionnels de production il faut
passer par des sous traitants donc
envoyé ma pièce au sous traitant le
sous-traitant va évaluer si c'est
difficile ou pas de les produire
ensuite ils valent à produire nous l'a
renvoyé donc s'il ya un petit défaut est
qu'il faut qu'on a modifié il faut qu'on
repasse par ce process à chaque fois
le projet pour l'année prochaine c'est
d'essayer d'organiser régulièrement le
jeudi après-midi quand ils n'ont pas
cours pour les étudiants qui veut qui le
souhaitent des petites formations
une formation à l'usinage formation a
l'impression 3d formation sur les
lézardes we know enfin l'équipe de
développement électronique
cet équipement du futur un vrai plus
pour les étudiants ingénieurs de
l'estaca qui pourront encore plus
imaginer inventer les mobilité de demain
depuis dix jours elle est en circulation
sur le territoire de la vallée de
chevreuse vous pouvez payer désormais
rang racines dans une vingtaine de
commerces de chevreuse et des alentours
la monnaie locale a été a lancé bonsoir
à christian portal bon synchronisme et
canal et vous êtes le président de
l'association l'aracine pour le collège
des particuliers alors la devise est
entrée en vigueur est entré en service
par dans le 23 juin dernier
dix jours plus tard quel premier bilan
tirez vous est ce que ce sont des débuts
timides encourageant inquiétant
peut-être non sont des débuts certes
timide on était en phase de test la
question l'objectif c'est de savoir de
prendre connaissance de toutes les deux
tous les bugs de toutes les difficultés
qu'on pourrait avoir
et donc on en rencontre quelques unes
c'est normal mais dans l'ensemble les
débuts sont plutôt encourageants
notamment du côté des particuliers qui
sont assez enthousiaste on a rencontré
lors de cette journée du 23
puis pendant les escapades gourmandes le
lendemain à mai au château de méry dont
on a rencontré beaucoup de
le comportement très favorable à la
monnaie alors l'idée c'était de faire de
la pédagogie leur expliquer pourquoi se
lancer cette monnaie certains étaient
déjà branché sur l'idée on a eu beaucoup
de retours favorables
et bien entendu ce n'est pas une devise
pas plus une monnaie
c'est en fait un moyen de paiement rien
d'autre ce qui simplifie énormément les
choses alors le seul point on peut dire
un point peut être noir sur ce lancement
c'est que vous regrettez tout le monde
ne joue pas encore le jeu peut-être pour
pour cette racine
voilà c'est un petit peu difficile du
côté des commerçants notamment du
commerçants de bouche qui sont pas
forcément les plus importants dans le
déplacement d'argent mais qui sont les
plus importants dans le dans l'appel
dans le phénomène d'appel parce que
c'est là qu'on va commencer à dépenser
de ses meilleurs dès le 23
certains d'entre nous sont allés déjà
dépensé de l'argent en racines moi même
j'ai dépensé les premiers de la première
transaction racines elle s'est fait le
jour de la livraison des billets sert
quelques jours encore avant sur
l'épicerie des molières d'ailleurs venu
avec quelques billets on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler
juste après alors pour payer justement
racines il faut être adhérent de
l'association est ce que vous avez
enregistré beaucoup d'adhésions là
depuis depuis dix jours alors on a
enregistré pas mal de des ions soit en
direct moment sur place quand on était
dans la rue ou dans les différentes
manifestations
on a enregistré sur le site également
pour l'instant n'est au moins 200
adhésions
ferme donc ils sont déjà faites et puis
plus entre 20 et lors d'une cinquantaine
de professionnels qui sont déjà engagés
surtout le surtout le set et là le
secteur il s'étend à combien une
vingtaine de commerces pour le moment ça
peut s'étendre alors qu matière de
commerce où il pas plus mais par contre
des professionnels beaucoup plus par des
curieux il ya des graphistes il ya des
comptables il ya deux prestataires qui
sont qui ne sont pas à proprement parler
des commerces et à terme l'idée c'est
vraiment que cela s'étende sur
l'ensemble du territoire du parc naturel
régional va progresser de 2 façons on va
progresser par contamination
c'est à dire que là pour l'institution
chevreuse on a un gros pôle qui va se
développer sur magny les hameaux
là on a déménagé en motivé on a une
commune on a une municipalité qui est
très motivé qui est très moteur dans
cette affaire là on a un groupe de
personnes là également très motivés donc
le prochaine étape
la prochaine étape c'est magny les
hameaux saint rémy les chevreuse qui est
entre les deux bien il va être contaminé
par les deux côtés forcément et puis
toute la vallée de l'hiver ça sera aussi
un élément de contamination et puis on
aura d'autres phénomènes qui seront des
phénomènes peut-être par sauts de puce
c'est là qu'on va avoir des bassins de
vie qui vont être très bon moteur par
exemple sur joueurs qu'on chartrain on a
un bassin ludique et très important sur
versa également on a des groupes locaux
qui fonctionnent qui sont très
dynamiques et qui donc vont faire
certainement démarrer la monnaie plus
vite que l'espace entre les deux ne
pourrait le laisser supposer pour la
petite anecdote la monnaie a été lancée
dans la première commune c'était à
molière à la mi juin c'est là où s'est
effectuée finalement la première
transaction aura six la première
transaction le jour de la sortie du
billet on a fait la première transaction
avec un commerçant extrêmement motivé ça
s'appelle a la pouvoir entre la poire et
le fromage aux molières donc en meulière
dans le département voisin de l'essonne
mais qui fait partie de ce territoire de
la vallée de chevreuse on revient aux
origines du projet les objectifs on
pense forcément à redynamiser le
commerce local aussi favoriser un lien
social construit une identité aussi
il contient une communauté de gens qui
vont fonctionner ensemble par exemple
des commerçants qui vont réapprendre à
fonctionner ensemble c'est pas le cas
actuellement parce que on s'aperçoit que
les les associations de commerçants sont
absolument désastreuse il se passe
frigout heureusement rien les réunions
on peut les comprendre c'est difficile
ils ont une des journées déjà lourde et
lendemain matin qui se lève tôt des
préoccupations personnelles assez
difficile avec des prêts et cetera donc
les préoccupations de groupes ne sont
pas tout à fait les leurs il faut que ça
redevienne notamment parce que c'est un
moteur considérable de leur propre
activité mais ça fout qu'ils arrivent à
comprendre qu'en aidant les autres ils
vont s'aider eux mêmes et ça c'est pas
facile alors parlons des billets vous
êtes venu avec quelques billets quelle
valeur de billets de racine peut-on
retrouver
et qu'est-ce qui figurent finalement sur
sur ses lots on a vingt racines 10 5 3
et 1
c'est donc des coupures de cette façon
là vous avez des personnages célèbres
l'historique ou pas d'ailleurs des
technologies qui peuvent être sur place
on à la fonderie de coubertin par
exemple on a des territoires évidemment
ou des éléments de patrimoine
et puis
et puis les paysages alors évidemment on
a quatre déclinaisons de billets par par
valeur faciale ce qui fait qu'il ya 20
billets différents qui vont arriver et
pour éviter par exemple les
falsifications et ce qu alors c'est vrai
papier les monnaies c'est du papier
second mandat et il en est qui donc avec
un filigrane à l'intérieur et qui en
plus à un vernis sur sur certaines
parties du billet qui fait qu' il est un
fal'cie fiable en fait il ya un copiable
par les scanners ou par l'est ou par les
photocopier combien de billets sont en
circulation actuellement alors on sait
de l'ordre de 13 milles mais c'est pour
une valeur alors ils sont faits en
circulation ils ont été imprimés
d'accord donc treize mille pour une
valeur de 73 mille euros donc 73 me
racine plus exactement etc et ces
billets ne seront en circulation qu'à
partir du moment où ils ont été
converties par des adhérents qu'ils ont
est donc là pour l'instant par exemple
ça se passe à deux niveaux mais toujours
en principe au niveau des comptoirs de
change ma deux conteurs de change à
chevreuse et un molière celui des
molières a converti près de 1000 euros
enracine donc en quelques dizaines de
jours moins de dix jours en tout cas on
peut retrouver toutes les informations
sur cette monnaie locale sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
on arrive est déjà la fin de cet
entretien merci à christian portal
d'avoir été avec nous et je rappelle que
vous êtes le président de l'association
l'aracine pour le collège des
particuliers merci d'avoir élevé mais
aussi de l'économie locale on passe à la
gastronomie adua terroir depuis cette
année l'an border est devenu le sandwich
préféré des français devant notre
traditionnel jambon beurre eric sanson
est un agriculteur d'auffargis il a
lancé une compétition le slow food
burger avec les plus grands chefs de la
région ceux du trianon palace de
versailles ou encore de l'abbaye des
vaux de cernay qui se sont mesurés
devant un jury camille lambert a assisté
aux dégustations trois barbecues six
cuisiniers et un jury lundi de juillet
la ferme de la petite aux gars auffargis
a pris des allures de top chef éric sens
aux agriculteurs et amoureux du terroir
a organisé la première compétition de
burgers slow food un mouvement
qui vise à sensibiliser au mariage entre
gastronomie et écologie c'est un
événement pour mettre en valeur les
avants des carcasses parce que bien
souvent les bouchers ne veulent
travailler que les arrières des
carcasses et non pas les avants c'est
une vache de la maison nourris
uniquement à l'herbe et au point dans
les meilleures conditions que des
produits locaux des fruits des légumes
qui viennent qui viennent du coin
locales aussi chez les participants
chefs étoilés comme frédéric l'art que
mains du trianon palace à versailles ou
maîtres restaurateurs comme christophe
cornier de l'auberge de l'élan mais
aussi des nouveaux venus
christophe parents a ouvert son
restaurant il ya trois ans c'est essayer
de rivaliser avec des grands mais ya pas
de prétention donc le but c'est d'être
dans le good de départager des choses un
généreuse
j'ai fait un burger qui était généreux
kippa pointilleux com ou raffiné mais il
ya du goût il ya de la saveur c'est ça
qui est intéressant
moi je suis parti sur un burger on vire
le burger 78 7 à 8 ingrédients on va
dire voilà donc on est sûr tout vient de
la petite boutique
de derrick et donc on a le du cochon la
poitrine de cochon fumée on avait la
viande de batterie ça laisse forcément à
une tomme de brebis
dcb du radis noir une sauce au poivre
donc assez rustique dans le jury présidé
par stéphane chicherit directeur de
l'école lenôtre difficile de désigner un
gagnant
les six candidats sont arrivés ex-aequo
tous très très différents les gars aient
bien joué je donc des saveurs très
différent des traditionnels des limites
asiatique desmyter années un certain m
travailler avec autre chose que du pain
donc très intéressant avis aux gourmands
les burgers créés pour l'occasion seront
à retrouver sur les tables des
restaurateurs un autre événement slow
food avec de la viande de gibier cette
fois aura lieu cet automne et vous
pourrez peut-être déguster ses burgers
devant un match de la coupe du monde de
football elle fait vibrer depuis trois
semaines déjà les fans du monde entier
par mieux est d élue des yvelines qui ne
ratent pas une miette de la compétition
michael et demi d'euros et patrick
jacques de dixmude ont rencontré trois
ils n'ont pas les mêmes convictions
politiques mais se rejoignent au moins
sur le football regard des jours de
match de l'équipe de france à bois
d'arcy parmi les supporters se cache le
maire de la commune philippe benassaya
grand passionné de football depuis sa
jeunesse l'homme politique tente de
garder son calme dans ces rencontres
sous haute tension
j'en fais attention pour été je peux
être beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
virulent mais oui on essaie de se calmer
quand même parce que voilà mais ça a
toujours été comme ça c'est plus fort
que moi une passion qu'il exporte
également dans son bureau à la mairie de
bois d'arcy
j'ai pas grand chose c'est vrai mais
j'ai des choses qui me tiennent à coeur
notamment
eh bien je sais pas si je me faire des
amis mais le maillot du psg
le le bal drapeau du psg c'est une
vieille passion
d'autres politiciens yvelinois
s'intéresse au monde du ballon rond
c'est le cas de luc miserez élu
d'opposition à trappes
après avoir pris sa première licence à 6
ans à maurepas il entraînait le club de
l'ouest rap une passion qu'il revendique
jusqu'à preuve du contraire on a encore
des êtres humains donc on a aussi des
passions ya aussi des émotions et donc
cette passion-là ça c'est certain que
elle ne me quittera pas sa passion l'a
également mené dans l'encadrement de
l'équipe d'argentine pendant la coupe du
monde 98
il a notamment assisté à la victoire de
l'argentine contre l'angleterre en
huitièmes de finale
le vice président de la fédération sud
américaine était prêt à rentrer dans le
vestiaire je lui dis président donnez
moi votre veste il s'est arrêté m'a dit
mais pourquoi je ne dis pas ce que je
crois que au moins elle sera sèche quand
vous ressortirez la coupe du monde 1998
a également fait vibrer le maire-adjoint
de trappes alliera b c'est à ce moment
là qu'il a commencé à jouer au football
et à collectionner les maillots de ses
équipes favorites
ça c'est le maillot de l'équipe
marocaine de foot génération 98 donc la
fameuse équipe qu'il y a 20 ans a déjà
disputé la coupe du monde
et donc pour moi ça rappelle des sacrés
souvenirs d'enfance pourront taper le
ballon dans mon quartier souvent avec le
maillot de l'équipe de france ou de
l'équipe du maroc
aujourd'hui ces trois politiques sont
moins présents sur les terrains de
football vu leur emploi du temps mais la
passion reste toujours présenté cette
coupe du monde 2018 n'a fait que raviver
la flamme cultura a dû en cours où les
enfants doivent sauver les bruits avec
le voyage d'amélie n'y découvre les
aventures d'une petite fille chasseur de
bruits l exposition est à découvrir
toute la semaine à la maison de quartier
auguste renoir reportage mélanie poker
vous voilà réveiller pour partir à
l'aventuré
un parcours à faire pour sauver les
bruits au pays d'amélie une petite fille
chasseur de bruits le matin comme tous
les matins elle allait vers son bol de
chocolat chaud quand un gros bruit même
un énorme bruit a dévoré tous les bruits
de la ville bien sûr avant que ça se
produise il y avait dans cette ville
plein de petits voiliers des gros bruits
des bruits d'où des bruits méchant donc
elle a décidé de partir à la chasse aux
bruits pour récupérer tous ces sons qui
donne de la couleur de l'eau d'heure de
l'effervescence
et du bonheur dans la vie mais il ya 15
ans l'exposition comporte 11 modules à
hauteur d'enfants touchés vue oui tous
les sens sont mobilisés le voyage
d'amélie est une exposition qu'on peut
toucher et pas seulement avec les yeux
c'est un moyen bien sûr de leur
permettre d'être à l'écouté faire
attention un petit peu ce qui se passe
autour d'eux et là d'une manière plus
sensible de regarder d'écouter de voir
de toucher et de vivre une expérience
sensorielle
c'est un camaïeu de tissus de couleurs
qu'on peut trouver dans le ciel avec des
textures différentes
donc là on est sur le toucher un petit
peu plus loin on a aussi des des galets
sur la plage donc là l'idée c'est
d'apprendre quelques notions de rythme
destiné aux enfants de 6 mois à 6 ans
l'exposition sensorielle vous emmène en
voyage celui de la petite amélie à vous
de vous glisser dans ses pas la baby
foot géant trampoline ou encore
tyrolienne la fête de coignières se
tenait samedi à l'espace alphonse-daudet
1500 personnes au total se sont rendus à
l'événement qui s'est terminée le soir
par un feu d'artifice un rendez vous
traditionnel pour célébrer l'arrivée des
beaux jours comme le précise le maire au
micro de nicolas landry chaque été c'est
une tradition maintenant de nous
retrouver dans l'enceinte de cet espace
alphonse daudet pour la fête de
coignières avec souvent le beau temps et
comme aujourd'hui peut-être avec une
chaleur excessive mais c'est toujours
très agréable et puis de voir tous les
enfants avec les différentes du jeu qui
attire beaucoup beaucoup d'animations et
c'est vraiment très agréable je suis
ravi de retrouver chaque année cette
tradition enfin malgré quelques gouttes
depuis l'été était célébrée également
dimanche à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
la maison elsa triolet aragon en
partenariat avec la commune accueillait
la cinquième édition de jardins en fête
une ode à la nature et à la poésie au
coeur du site de 6 hectares et des
associations locales des compagnies de
spectacles et théâtre de rue étaient de
la partie pour proposer une dizaine
d'activités dont un piano manèges les
propos sont collectées par nicolas
landry
l'objectif c'est de faire connaître des
associations locales qui se battent au
quotidien pour faire vivre les jardins
donc ça peut être les jardins partagés
ça peut être des associations de
peinture
l'idée c'est de proposer aux gens et de
faire connaître des associations locales
à notre public c'est la fin de ce
journal à suivre dans un instant le
dernier numéro de la saison du 7 8 et co
présentée par aurélie rose très belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]